hi I'm I'm Gigi from Collider my uncle
is not here today he gave my job and I
interviewed the cast of playing with
fire take a look
see you guys we create the way you guys
try and I'm not just flow ups in it was
great
it's tarded I was a fan of John Cena
when I was younger I really liked
watching him wrestle but also he's just
like really sweet and down-to-earth I'm
good which I'm not that I wasn't
expecting that but it surprised me how
long did it take to make the home
they've been working on this movie
before we even got involved for 14 years
developing them and then when we started
we started in January and we ended in
April and then we just finished and
that's just production and then we just
finished post-production editing in and
putting it all together about two weeks
ago when they actually started rolling
and shooting the movie it was actually
fairly quick because it was really
people were very professional so we and
the kids the kids were fantastic so kind
of everyone did their homework and when
you have a crew that does their homework
they're prepared when they're prepared
in school well the party scene was fun
all of the stunts were really fun and
honestly hanging out between scenes just
like playing and drawing and stuff was
really fun I always have fun making it
like you get you get to play dress-up
and you get to have fun then you get to
tell jokes but I think when audiences
see it and enjoy your effort I think
that's the most enjoyable part
was it really you driving like the ATM
in the track I guess I did actually
drive the ATV for a little bit but a lot
of it was green screen stuff and just
like trying to act like I was driving
you know we were shaking that truck yeah
it was all Andy shaking the trust him so
much fun oh you're so cute
very drooly but so very good so in real
life mashers name was Noah and then what
was the other two dogs that played
Master Noah and hardly came ever is name
but there's a boy dog and a girl dog and
they were both great and they were
lovely and we were allowed we were
allowed to pet them sometimes and play
with them and that was very relaxing
they were so awesome and well-behaved
but like this big movie did you worry
about being fined I didn't actually I
was never worried about being slighted
and now I realize I probably should have
been concerned about that and I am
concerned for my well-being for the rest
of my time here No No thank you for
reminding me I'm gonna let you in a
little secret I hosted the Kids Choice
Awards at once twice
I believe I hold the record for
retaining the most and gallons of slime
and Nickelodeon history because the
first year I hosted I went to
Nickelodeon straight away and said
listen I want to break the slime record
and they're like you know this is a Kids
Choice Awards
we like slime everybody a lot I don't
care and then they had me back for
another year and I kicked the door and
again I said we're breaking the record
again boy did we ever was it like
challenging me the whole I got all of
the five secret
well you're dealing with something
that's really unpredictable so safety is
the number-one thing for everybody for
our actors on set when they were in the
cabin it was all on fire
that's real fire and so you want to make
sure the actors would say well make sure
your crew is saved we had Fire
Department around us every time we had
fire so it's really about just making
sure that you're ready for anything just
two deep breaths - or deep breaths on be
good all right okay and that's kind of
how the movie was we just did that I
said we'll be playing spy this so much
fun you can see it - on November 8th
[Music]